foreign
[Music]
last seen I was back from the emergency
room the following day and wondering
what had happened to me and like all of
you here hopefully all of you here I
have the power of R and R studio and I
know how to do an internet search so I
found a blog post that told me how to
export all the data from the Apple
Health export and that's what I did and
I also know ggplot and I did this chart
this is the very chart that I took with
me to my doctor a couple days later it's
not a very fancy chart
uh the vertical axis shows my pulse the
horizontal axis is the time of day Zero
is midnight and
um
you can see about uh
there is the event that sent me to the
emergency room my perception of the
event that sent me to the emergency room
in the middle of the night about 1 30
a.m this is when I was upset got up took
some bicarbonate of soda the whole thing
did not last very long went back to bed
went to sleep while I was asleep my
pulse was going up gradually which is
very unusual and then uh hit that and
off I went and that's the story of my
visit to the emergency room which was
not a big deal uh it's but it does
provide an example of how your health
tracker is basically making a recording
of your life with data so in order to do
this chart and and to look into this a
little bit more I had to sort of uh dig
into the Apple Health export and the
first thing that sort of blew me away
was just the sheer volume of data never
in my professional life have I worked
with a data set nearly as large as me
and I was kind of excited about that and
it was kind of fun so 3.9 million rows
1.2 million rows in the last year alone
I mean as we speak I am adding rows to
the data
um and uh
I also did some additional stuff to try
to say was this night
unusual and went back and tried to look
for other examples and didn't find
anything which was a good thing so
you have I have all these this
incredible amount of data but it's it's
you think of it as a recording of your
life but if you had an audio recording
or a visual recording of your life most
of those moments wouldn't be very
interesting and the same is true of the
data there's a lot of data which is dull
um it's 70 of the data is the sort of
low level stuff your heart rate your
active energy as you're moving around
and so on but uh there are a bunch of
summary measures and other categories
and measures basically this is what you
see on the health app on the iPhone or
you see sort of these icons with these
categories of uh of things that it's
keeping track of and
underneath each of those or with each of
those a set of individual measures and
this is the measure the ones that would
fit on the screen there are quite a few
more than this and so you can
get into any one of these things each of
them has a sort of a story and maybe
relevant to different factors so you
have heart rate of course but you but
you have
um
your uh stuff about sleep which is not
showing here and step count and things
like that
um so let's
talk about what is the Apple Health
export so basically uh on the iPhone
there is a database of all of this
information and that's what's sitting
underneath the health app and apple if
you're an app developer on the iPhone
the API to that database is called the
health kit and what's happening is is
measurements are being fed in from the
watch or being fed in from the phone
they're also coming in from other apps
for example I have lose it on my phone
which is a calorie counting app which I
have occasionally used I have a blood
pressure cuff which has a Bluetooth
connection to my phone I also have it
set up so it has a connection to my
electronic health record so it's all of
the records from my doctor all of that
goes into this database and it becomes
accessible via the export and when you
actually ask for an export in my case it
takes it about nine minutes before it
can assemble this whole thing and then I
can export it to my laptop and load it
into r now when I unzip this export file
on my laptop I think it's like three and
a half gigabytes which again is sort of
crazy it's a very wordy firm format
there's basically one table that I care
about and that one is uh before I
process it in is like that one is like
one and a half gigabytes so it is a tidy
table this table you know you have to
tidy it up it's already a tidy table
it's got a one row per measurement for
my
3.9 measurements or whatever 3.9 million
whatever it was
and each row has a start time stamp an
end time stamp the type of what is being
measured the value and the source of the
measurement the phone or my blood
pressure cuff or whatever and the
version of the software that did that
measurement
so you'll focus on type and value
usually but you need to pay attention to
the source and the version as well the
source so for example your step count is
being produced by the watch but the
phone is also producing a step count
they both get fed in if you don't pay
attention to the source you end up
double counting and I've had that happen
with other measures as well so let's
look at a measure
this is resting heart rate I'm
interested in what's the trend in
resting heart rate we have uh on the
vertical axis heart rate on the
horizontal axis we have more than four
years worth of data here one point per
day and all of this feels very personal
to me so I look at a chart like this and
I look at this thing and I look at the
smooth line that I put through this
chart and I say whoa what's going on
here why is this line doing this is is
there something about me is I is should
I be worried about this
trap you can fall into by spending too
much time with your own data should I
worry about this
well let's look at the version so the
vertical green bars show the major
versions of the watch OS software and
you see that basically what's happening
is between version 6 and version seven
they change the measurement so what
happened with version seven
they added sleep tracking so before
version seven when they were saying
resting heart rate what they were
usually ending up with was my heart rate
at three in the morning or when I was
asleep you know near the lowest heart
rate of the day and they basically
redefined the measure let's say improve
the measure so that it was only while
you were awake
you have to watch out for this thing
with any data set you definitely have to
watch out for it with the Apple Health
export sometimes there are Clues to
things like this but there are sometimes
there are not sometimes it's a black box
and you got to figure this out on your
own I'm going to show one more example
because I like it a lot this is a
measure I'm very interested in VO2 max
this is a measure of your aerobic
fitness when it's done directly you're
in a lab and they're measuring your
exhaled gases and seeing how well you're
using oxygen obviously you don't do that
with an iPhone so they have an algorithm
that
estimates your VO2 max based on while
you're walking a certain distance uh
you're looking at your heart rate and
the speed that you're traveling the
distance I look at this chart I'm
actually pretty good at inventing uh
explanations for things that don't have
explanations but I look at this chart
and it I I can't see anything but if we
add in diversion numbers we see that
apple is working on improving their
measures uh or I assume that's what's
going on and so you see the between
version four or version five and let's
see I got it five percent five six it
goes up then it goes back down and then
what's been happening more recently as
less clear to me what's going on with
versions maybe stuff is maybe it isn't
uh I don't I don't know and uh you just
have to look at the data and see now I
would love to know what my long-term
trend is for this to watch this over
time but I look at this and certainly
for the earlier years now there's
nothing I can do with that
um and so for all of these measures you
can dive in and get into uh stories like
this
so let's get into one last measure which
is different than all the others which
is the electrocardiogram which was added
uh with the Apple watch for
this is different because it actually
has FDA approval as a actual medical
device the doing the electrocardiogram
and then also the software that
evaluates whether it's showing signs of
atrial fibrillation atrial fibrillation
is a a problem with the electrical
signal in the upper chamber of the heart
I should emphasize for this population
that it's generally a a problem among
the elderly not a problem for the age
demographic that is typical of this
conference you actually do the
electrocardiogram by putting your finger
on the stem of the watch as shown in the
picture here and then on to the right we
have an actual little example of the
electrocardiogram strip that it produces
that strip is strip indicates atrial
fibrillation that was from October of
2020 that's the second time I had an
episode of atrial fibrillation in seven
years uh uh I am I am elderly
um so it's not so uh far-fetched got
into the news recently because the John
fetterman the Senate candidate in
Pennsylvania was in atrial fibrillation
and it contributed to his stroke so what
do I do in a situation like this well
I do a Gigi plot so again I went to when
I had my episode of atrial fibrillation
I went to the emergency room my doctor
is not so surprised when I walk in with
a Judicial
um I got a I have a beautiful blood
pressure plot
um so this in the case of atrial
fibrillation I literally used the same
function that I had written
several years before for the first plot
in in this case I have all the raw data
from the atrial fibrillation episode
which actually starts about 12 30. what
happened during the day was I was having
a normal day I went out for exercise in
the morning my heart rate's slightly
elevated all perfectly normal sit down
for lunch part way through lunch I felt
funny check and realized something is
going on so I I have the raw data for
the electric for the atrial fibrillation
but I don't have the expertise to do
anything with that that's just beyond me
but what I was able to do was to take
the background heart rate information
and to put the atrial fibrillation
episode in the context of the rest of
the day and there is some slight
relevance to to the when I was
discussing with this with the doctor
because what I could show was that
within a minute or two of after the
episode started there's an indication
there that shows I was doing
electrocardiogram so I could tell this
is evidence that I knew when I went into
atrial fibrillation sometimes people are
have signed don't know they're a atrial
fibrillation but I knew and and you can
also see that I came out of it uh
before they hooked me up to an
electrocardiogram in the emergency room
uh it actually goes on and off like
throwing a light switch so there was
none of these things I'm showing you are
have dramatic effects on my medical
treatment uh it's but in this particular
case there was some slight advantage in
having a discussion about whether I
needed to go in blood thinners and
whatever
um but the general point is is that this
stuff shows you a picture of your life
there's a lot of data there if you are
have just looked at Palmer Penguins one
too many times and you want to try
something else with deep hire you got
you may have you know hundreds of
thousands millions of rows of data that
you may find more interesting than
Palmer penguins so I've done a series of
blog posts about this if you have more
interest in figuring out how to do this
there's a lot more information there and
there's also a url url with an example
of some other things that people have
done uh with their data
[Applause]
[Music]